eunuch started
being developed 50 years ago maybe more
than 50 years ago
can you tell the story like you
described in your new book of how
eunuchs was created
if i can remember that far back it was
some while ago
um so i think the gist of it is that at
bell labs
in 1969 there were a group of people who
had just
finished working on the multix project
which was
itself a follow-on to ctss so we can go
back
sort of an infinite regress in time but
the ctss was a very very very nice time
sharing system it was very nice to use i
actually used it as
that summer i spent in cambridge in
1966.
what was the hardware there right so
what's the operating system what's the
hardware there what's the cts look like
so ctss looked like uh kind of like a
standard
time sharing system certainly at the
time it was the only time sharing of no
let's go back to the basic what's the
time frame okay in the beginning was the
word and the word
and then there was time sharing systems
yeah if we go back into let's call it
the 1950s and early
1960s most computing was done on very
big
computers physically big although not
terribly powerful by
today's standards that were maintained
in
very large rooms and you use things like
punch cards to write your programs on
and talk to them so you would take a
deck of cards write your program on it
send it over a counter hand it to an
operator and
some while later back would come
something that said oh you made a
mistake
and then you'd recycle and so it's very
very slow so the idea of time sharing
was that you take
basically that same computer but connect
to it
with something that looked like an
electric typewriter
they could be a long distance away it
could be closed but fundamentally what
the operating system did
was to give each person who was
connected to it and wanting to do
something
a small slice of time on
um to do a particular job so i might be
editing
a file so i would be typing and every
time i hit a keystroke the operating
system would wake up and said oh he
typed
character let me remember that then i'd
go back to doing something else would be
going around and around a group
of people who were trying to get
something done giving each
a small slice of time
and giving them each the illusion that
they pretty much had the whole machine
to themselves and hence
time sharing that is sharing the
computing time
resource of the computer among a number
of people who are doing it without the
individual people being aware that
there's others
in a sense the illusion the feelings
that you the machinist
your own pretty much that was the idea
yes you had
if it were well done and if it were fast
enough and other people weren't doing
too much
you did have the illusion that you had
the whole machine to yourself and it was
very much better than the punch card
model
and so ctss the compatible time sharing
system
was i think arguably the first of these
it was done
i guess technically 64 or something like
that it ran on an ibm 7094
slightly modified to have twice as much
memory as the norm
it had two banks of 32k words
instead of one so 32k
words yeah each word was 36 bits so call
it you know about 150 kilobytes
times two so by today's standard sets
down in the noise
but at the time that was a lot of memory
and memory was expensive
so uh ctss was just a wonderful
environment
to work on it was done by the people at
mit led by
uh fernando corbitov corby who died just
earlier this year
and a bunch of other folks and then so i
spent the summer of 66 working on that
had a great time met a lot of really
nice people and
indirectly knew of people
at bell labs who were also working
on a follow-on to ctss that was called
multics
the multix was meant to be the system
that would do everything that ctss did
but do it better for a larger population
all the usual stuff now the actual time
sharing the scheduling
uh how much what's the algorithm that
performs the scheduling what's that look
like how much magic is there what are
the metrics
how does it all work in the beginning so
the answer is i don't have a clue i
think the basic idea was nothing more
than
who all wants to get something done
suppose things are very quiet in the
middle of the night
then i get all the time that i want
suppose that you and i are contending at
high noon for something like
that then probably the simplest
algorithm is a round robin one that
gives you a bit of time gives me a bit
of time
and then we could adapt to that like
what are you trying to do
are you text editing or are you
compiling or something and we might
adjust the scheduler according to things
like that
so okay so multics was trying to just do
some of the
clean it up a little bit well it was
meant to be much more than that so
multix was the multiplexed information
and computing service and it was meant
to be
a very large thing that would provide
computing utility
something that where you could actually
think of it as just a plug in the wall
service
sort of like cloud computing today yeah
same idea
but 50 odd years earlier and so
what multix offered was a richer
operating system environment
a piece of hardware that was better
designed for doing the kind
of sharing of resources and presumably
lots of other things
do you think people at that time had the
dream of what
cloud computing is starting to become
now which is computing is everywhere
that you can just
plug in almost no you know and
you never know how the magic works you
just kind of plug in
at your little computation that you need
to perform and it does it
was that the dream i don't know where
that was the dream i wasn't part of it
at that point remember i was an intern
for
summer but my sense is given that it was
over 50 years ago yeah they had that
idea that it was an
information utility that it was
something where if you had a computing
task
to do you could just go and do it now
i'm
betting that they didn't have the same
view of
computing for the masses let's call it
the idea that you know
your grandmother would be shopping on
amazon i don't think that was part of it
but if your grandmother were a
programmer it might be very easy for her
to go and
use this kind of utility what was your
dream of computers at that time what did
you see as the future of computers
because you have predicted what
computers are today
that makes sense oh short answer
absolutely not i have no clue
i'm not sure i had a dream it was a
dream job in the sense that i really
enjoyed what i was doing i was
surrounded by really really nice people
cambridge is a very fine city to live in
in the summer less so in the winter when
it snows but in the summer it was a
delightful time and so i really enjoyed
all of that stuff
and i learned things and i think the
good fortune
of being there for summer led me then to
get a summer job at bell labs the
following summer
and that was kind of useful for the
future
so this bell labs is this magical
legendary place so first of all where is
bell labs
and can you start
talking about that journey towards unix
at bell labs
yeah so bell labs is physically
scattered around
at the time scattered around new jersey
the primary location
is in a town called murray hill where a
location called murray hill is actually
the across the boundary between two
small towns in new jersey called new
providence and berkeley heights
uh think of it as about 15 20 miles
straight west of new york city
and therefore about an hour north of
here in princeton
and at that time it had make up a number
three or four thousand people there
many of whom had phds and mostly doing
physical sciences
chemistry physics materials kinds of
things
but very strong math and it
rapidly growing interest in computing as
people realized you could do things with
computers
that you might not have been able to do
before you could replace
labs with computers that had worked on
models of what was going on
so that was that was the essence of bell
labs and again i wasn't a permanent play
there i was
that was another internship i got lucky
in internships
i mean if you could just linger in a
little bit what was the
what was in the air there because some
of this the number of nobel prizes the
number of touring awards and just
legendary computer scientists that come
from their inventions including
developments including unix it's just uh
it's unbelievable so
is is was there something special about
that place oh i think there was very
definitely something special
i mentioned the number of people so very
large number of people
very highly skilled and working in an
environment where there was always
something interesting to work on
because the goal of bell labs which was
a small part of a t
which provided basically the country's
phone service the goal of atmt was to
provide service for everybody
and the goal of bell labs was to try and
make that service
keep getting better so improving service
and that meant
doing research on a lot of different
things
physical devices like the transistor or
fiber optical cables or microwave
systems
all of these things the labs worked on
and it was
kind of just the beginning of real boom
times in computing
as well because when i was there i went
there first in 66.
so computing was at that point fairly
young
and so people were discovering that you
could do lots of things with computers
so how's eunuchs born so
multics in spite of having an enormous
number of really good ideas lots of good
people working on it fundamentally
didn't live up at least in the short run
and i think ultimately really ever
to its goal of being this information
utility
it was too expensive and certainly what
was promised was delivered
much too late um and so in roughly the
beginning of 1969 bell labs
pulled out of the project the project at
that point had included
mit bell labs and
general electric general electric made
computers so general electric was the
hardware
operation so bell labs realizing this
wasn't going anywhere on a time scale
they cared about
pulled out his project and this left
several people
with an acquired taste for really really
nice computing environments
but no computing environment and so they
started thinking about
what could you do if you're going to
design a new operating system
that would provide the same kind of
comfortable computing as ctss had but
also the facilities
of something like multix brought forward
and so they did a lot of paper design
stuff and at the same time ken thompson
found what is characterized as a little
used pdp seven
where he started to do experiments with
file systems just how do you store
information on a computer in an
efficient way and then this famous story
that his wife went away
to california for three weeks taking
their one-year-old son
and three weeks and he sat down and
wrote an operating system
which ultimately became unix so software
productivity was good in those days
so pdp what's the pdp seven so it's a
piece of hardware
yeah it's a piece of part where it was
one of on early machines made by
digital equipment corporation deck and
it was a mini computer so called it
had i would have to look up the numbers
exactly but it had a very small amount
of memory maybe
16k 16-bit words or something like that
relatively slow
probably not super expensive maybe again
making this up i'd have to look it up
a hundred thousand dollars or something
like that which is not super expensive
in those days right
it was expensive it was enough that you
and i probably wouldn't be able to buy
one but a modest group of people could
get together
but in any case in it came out if i
recall in 1964 so by 1969 it was
getting a little obsolete and that's why
it was little used
if you can sort of comment what do you
think it's like to write an operating
system like that so that process that
ken went through
in three weeks uh because you were
i mean you're part of that process you
contributed a lot
to uh to enix's early development so
what
do you think it takes to do that first
step that first kind of
from design to reality on the pdp well
let me correct one thing i had nothing
to do with it so
i did not write it i have never written
operating system code
and so i don't know now an operating
system is simply
code and this first one wasn't very big
but it's something that lets you run
processes if some
lets you execute some kind of code that
has been written that lets you store
information for periods of time
so that it doesn't go away when you turn
the power off or reboot or something
like that
and there's a kind of a core set of
tools that are technically not
part of an operating system but you
probably need them in this case ken
wrote
an assembler for the pdp7 that worked he
needed a text editor so that he could
actually create
text he had the file system stuff that
he had been working on and then the rest
of it was just a way to
load things executable code from the
file
system into the memory give it control
and then
recover control when it was finished or
in some other way
quit what was the code written in the
primarily the programming language was
it an assembly
yeah pdp seminal assembler that can
create it
these things were assembly language
until probably the
um call it 1973 or 74 something like
that
i forgive me if it's a dumb question but
it feels like a daunting task to write
any kind of complex system and assembly
absolutely
that's it feels like impossible to do
any kind of what we think of as software
engineering
with assembly because to work on a big
picture
sort of i think it's hard i it's been a
long time since i wrote assembly
language it is absolutely true that in
some of the language if you make a
mistake nobody tells you there are no
training wheels whatsoever
um and so stuff doesn't work now what
and there's no debuggers well there
could be debuggers but that re
that's the same problem right how do you
actually um
get something that will help you debug
it so part of it is is
um an ability to see the
big picture now these systems were not
big in the sense that today's pictures
are so the big picture was in some sense
more manageable
i mean then realistically there's an
enormous variation in the capabilities
of programmers
and ken thompson who did that first one
is is kind of the singularity
in my experience of programmers uh
with no disrespect to you or even to me
several leagues removed i know there's
levels
there's it's it's a it's a fascinating
thing that there are
unique stars in particular in the
programming space and at a particular
time you know the time matters too the
timing of when that person comes along
and the uh a wife does have to leave
like there's this weird timing that
happens that and then all of a sudden
something beautiful is created
i mean how does it make you feel that
there's a system
that was created in in three weeks or
maybe you can even say on a whim but not
really but of course
quickly that is now you could think of
most of the computers in the world run
on a unix-like
system right
how do you inter like uh if you kind of
assume from the alien perspective if you
were just observing earth
that also these computers took over the
world and they started from this little
initial seed of eunuchs how does that
make you feel
it's quite surprising and and you asked
earlier about prediction
the answer is no there's no way you
could predict that kind of evolution
and i don't know whether it was
inevitable or just a whole sequence of
blind luck i suspect
more of the latter and um so i look at
it and think
gee that's kind of neat
i think the real question is what does
ken think about that
because he's the guy arguably from whom
it really
came you know tremendous contributions
from dennis ritchie and then others
around
in that bell labs environment but you
know if you had to pick a single person
that would be ken so you've uh written
in your book
unix a history and a memoir are there
some memorable human stories
funny or profound from that time they
just kind of stand out
oh there's a lot of them in a sense and
again it's a question of can you
resurrect them
in real time this memory fails
but i think part of it was that bell
labs at the time was
was a very special kind of place to work
because there were a lot of interesting
people and the environment was very very
open
and free it was a very cooperative
environment very friendly environment
and so if you had an interesting problem
you go and talk to somebody and they
might help you with the solution
and and it was a kind of a fun
environment too in which people
did strange things and um
often tweaking the bureaucracy in one
way or another
so rebellious and in certain kinds of
ways in some ways yeah
absolutely i think most people didn't
take too kindly to the bureaucracy and
i'm sure the bureaucracy
put up with an enormous amount that they
didn't really want to
you